Which of the following triangles
are similar to triangle ABC?
So this is triangle ABC.
Before we even look
at these options,
let's remind ourselves of what
it means for two triangles
to be similar.
There's multiple ways
of thinking about it.
The classical definition
of similar triangles
is that all the corresponding
angles are equivalent.
So for example, if these
two are similar triangles,
then if this angle
corresponds to that one,
then these two angles
are going to be the same.
If this angle
corresponds to this one,
then these two angles
are going to be the same.
And if this angle
corresponds to this one,
then these two angles
are going to be the same,
and these are similar.
And the reason why similarity
is useful is because that tells
you the ratio between
corresponding sides
are going to be the same.
So for example, if this side
has length 2 and this side
has length 1, then the ratio
of this side to this side
is 2 to 1.
The corresponding sides here
are this side and this side.
So they would also have
to have a 2 to 1 ratio.
So for example, this could
be 4, and this could be 2-- 2
to 1 ratio.
4/2 is the same thing as 2/1.
Or it could be 7 to 3 and 1/2.
Or it could be 10 to 5.
It would always have a 2 to
1 ratio if this had a 2 to 1
ratio and if these
are similar triangles.
Now, in the context
of a line and slope,
I'll think about
another one, another way
of thinking about similarity.
If you have two
right triangles--
so let's say this is one right
triangle right over here--
so if you have one right
triangle right over there
and you have another right
triangle just like that,
if you have two right triangles
and the ratio of the two
sides on either side
of the right angle
correspond to each other-- so
if the ratio of this magenta
side to this green side is
the same in this triangle
as it is in this triangle--
then we are similar.
So for example, if these
are two right triangles
and if this is a, let's
say, this side is length 6
and this side is length 9
and this side is length 2
and this side is
length 3, these are
going to be similar triangles.
You have an angle
right over here.
And the ratio of 6/2 is
the same thing as 3/1.
The ratio of 9/3 is the
same thing as 3 to 1.
These are similar.
Now, why am I telling
you that in the context
of this right over here?
Well, we have a line and
you connect any two points
on the line, let's say
point c to point a,
the ratio of your change
in y over your change
in x is always going
to be constant.
And when you have a trying to
constructed this way, where you
have your change in x is
going perfectly horizontal
and your change in y is
going perfectly vertical,
it's going to be
a right triangle.
And so any right
triangle you construct
between two points
on the line this way,
they're going to be
similar, because your ratio
between your change in y--
notice if you go from point c
to point a, you can point
c is at 3, point a is at 9.
This is literally
your change in y.
Going from 3 to 9,
you increased by 6.
Your change in y is equal
to 6 right over here.
And in the horizontal direction,
this base of this triangle
right over here, this
is your change in x.
c is that point at
your x value is at 1.
a, your x value is 3.
So you went, your change
in x is equal to 2.
And any right
triangle you construct
this way between any two
points on a line, this ratio,
your change in y over your
change in x, which in this case
is 6/2, is going to be constant.
And since that ratio is
going to be constant,
it's a right triangle, any
two triangles constructed
in this way with the line
between two points on the line,
they are going to be similar.
Now, let's look at our options.
So triangle ADG-- well,
once again, the hypotenuse,
just like triangle ABC, the
hypotenuse is still our line.
We are essentially
thinking about the base
of the triangle is the
change in x between going
from between our x value
for d and our x value for a.
And this height right over here
or this side right over here,
this is our change in y going
from y equals negative 3 to y
equals 9.
So this is our change in y.
We know that your change
in y over your change in x
is going to be
constant for a line.
This is a right triangle.
So these two triangles are
definitely going to be similar.
And if you want to break out
a little bit of your geometry,
it's not hard to prove that
the corresponding angles are
equivalent, using a little
bit of your parallel lines
and transversals of
parallel lines knowledge.
Now, let's look at triangle BEF.
Well, this is a right
triangle, but its hypotenuse
does not sit on--
so triangle BBEBEF.
So this triangle is
a right triangle.
But its hypotenuse does
not sit on the line.
Now, it could be similar,
but you could even
see that this line right here
has a different inclination.
It has a different slope.
So that's a pretty good
sign that these are not
going to be similar triangles.
And if you really
wanted to verify it,
you could look at the
ratio of your change in y
over your change in x.
And in fact, let's
just do that for fun,
just to prove to ourselves
that it's not similar.
To go from F to B, you're
going from negative 6
to 3-- 3 minus negative 6.
I'll just say this length right
over here, BF, is equal to 9.
I'm not going to say
change in y over change
in x, because we're not going
between two points on the line.
I'm just going to look at
the length of this line.
The length of this line is 9.
The length of this line
right over here-- let's see,
we're going from
negative 1 to 3-- is 4.
So the ratio of 9
to 4 is definitely
not the same as the ratio
of 6 to 2 or 3 to 1.
So we can rule BEF out.
Now, let's look at EFG.
Well, once again, this
isn't sitting on the line.
That doesn't necessarily
mean it's not similar.
But you can even see the
inclination of its hypotenuse
is very different than
the line right over here.
And you see the
ratio of these sides.
You have a side length
3, side length 4.
The ratio of 3 to 4 is
definitely not 6 to 2.
If this was somehow oriented
different, the ratio of 4 to 3
is also not the
ratio of 6 to 2--
I guess this is the 6 to 200
the 6 to 2 or the 3 to 1.
So we can rule this
one out as well.
And then finally, triangle
BDG-- well, once again-- you're
tired of me saying
this-- triangle BDG,
its hypotenuse does
not sit on the line.
Its hypotenuse has a very
different inclination
or a very different slope
than the line itself.
So this is not going to
be a similar triangle.
You can often eyeball it.
The similar triangle
will look the same.
It'll have the same proportions.
They don't necessarily have
to have different sides,
different sizes.
But they can have
One is a scaled up
version of the other.
And you can see here, this
triangle right over here
looks very different
than triangle ABC.
And you can even verify
that the ratio of this side
right over here to this side
is very different than 3 to 1.
So we can rule this
one out as well.
So let's actually input
that and make sure
that we actually got
the right answer.
So let me input it right there.
And we got the right answer.